New data has accurately measured
and potentially confirmed
some mind-blowing theories
about the universe.
Anthony here for DNews, and
space is big, super big.
Think of the biggest thing in
your house and then double it
and space is at least that big.
OK.
That might have been a little
nonspecific, but to be fair,
we've been dealing with some
wildly different estimates
about just how big
the universe is.
But now thanks to new
measurement techniques
discover by the Baryon
Oscillation Spectroscopic
Survey Collaboration, we've
got a more accurate handle
on the size of--
well everything,
the whole everything.
Knowing how far
away something is
is very important in astronomy.
The way something looks visually
through a telescope means
something different depending
on how far away it is .
And as things get
farther and farther away,
our ability to accurately gauge
those distances gets harder.
20 years ago, estimates about
the size of the universe
varied as much as 50%.
But now, the
appropriately-named BOSS
just analyzed data from the
Sloan Foundation telescope
in New Mexico of the largest
sample of the universe ever,
1,277,503 galaxies across
6 billion light years
to an accuracy of 1%.
We have got a 6
billion light-year map.
So how did they do it?
They use baryon
acoustic oscillations.
Basically, as the universe was
rapidly expanding after the Big
Bang, it put out these
waves of pressure
like ripples that set up how
galaxies are distributed today.
They're spherical, and the team
used the radius of the BAOs
as a sort of unit of
measurement creating
this giant cosmic ruler half
a billion light years long.
And the team says
not only does this
allow accurate measurement of
distances to celestial bodies,
but it will also help to
figure out other big questions
like the rate of
expansion of the universe.
The BOSS data also
supports Einstein's idea
of the cosmological constant,
meaning that dark energy exists
and has remained constant
throughout the history
of the universe.
It also means we can
start figuring out
more about just what
exactly dark energy is
and how it works.
Another insane
thing they found, it
looks like our universe is
flat rather than curved.
Flat here means that
if you go forward
in space in a
straight line, you're
going to keep going
in the same direction
like drawing a line
on a sheet of paper.
A positively-curved
universe, on the other hand,
would be like going forward
but drawing a straight line
on a ball.
And if our universe
is flat, that
means it goes on infinitely
and is forever expanding though
at a constantly-slower
rate, which
is a really amazing thing
to picture during the day,
but gives me an
existential crisis
if I do it in bed at night.
The really amazing thing,
BOSS isn't even done.
It's got data from about
a million more galaxies
to map and analyze
over the next month.
And based on those
results, the team
will run computer simulations
of mock universes,
and tweak their findings, and
then do it all over again,
looking for changes that
will help them even more
accurately measure just
how quickly our universe is
expanding and
helping them to fill
in more holes in our map of it.
This is huge, literally,
because it is the universe,
but also in terms
of understanding
how the universe works.
I think it broke my brain.
How are you guys holding up?
Let me know, and
subscribe for more DNews.